When a person considers and analyzes the functions
of the brain, the brain is analyzing itself.
As far as the human brain is concerned, it
is the only thing on planet earth to have
the ability to become self-aware of its own
existence.
Not only is the brain aware of its existence,
but it also spends its entire life trying
to understand why.
Existing is not enough for the brain.
The brain must also understand why.
It is the single question “why?” that
separates human from all other species on
planet earth.
Ever since we are old enough to utter words,
it seems as though our favorite word is, “why?”
When we are a child, we ask things like why
the sky is blue or why things die.
Our parents might give us their best answers,
but the spirit of our question remains restless
and fundamentally unanswered.
Our brain is so confused.
It does not understand how it can be both
conscious enough to ask questions but not
conscious enough to uncover all of the answers?
It taunts itself with this perpetual cycle,
trying to find a way out of its infinite madness,
but it only knows how to digs its self deeper.
So what do we do?
Do we follow our brain into its hole of madness?
Yes and no.
We must be careful when we live with the word,
“why?” because it is a double-edged sword.
On one side, it is a wasted existence to disregard
our inquisitive nature and not try to improve
life and human understanding.
But on the other side, identifying with this
infinite inquest fills us with a sense of
constant dissatisfaction and restrains us
from ever truly stopping and enjoying our
individual lives.
It is a balance between both sides that we
must learn and apply.
We must ask “why?”
but learn how to live happily without always
having an answer for it.
If our well-being is dependent on all the
“whys?”
being answered, we become like a dog chasing
its own tail.
We will constantly chase our brain, running
in circles, longing for all the answers to
life.
But once a dog catches its tail, it realizes
that the tail was a part of it the whole time
and it has only bitten itself.
In the same way, people who try to find the
experience of life by merely chasing after
it, suffer.
Just like the tail is attached to the dog,
life is already attached to us.
We do not always need to chase it.
Sometimes we just need to live it and enjoy
its mystery.